la reunión duró aproximadamente una hora
y no ninguno de los dos líderes quiso
hablar con la prensa sin embargo antes
de esta reunión bilateral en el salón
oval de la Casa Blanca se refirieron al
tema de Ucrania el canciller Olaf dijo
que este era un año muy importante
teniendo en cuenta la nueva ofensiva
rusa para tratar de seguir ganando
terreno en Ucrania hay que recordar que
esta es la Segunda visita del canciller
alemán desde que llegó al poder hace 15
meses la primera visita fue precisamente
dos semanas antes de que empezara la
invasión rusa a Ucrania al respecto Joe
biden dijo que Pues habría que centrar
el interés todas las fuerzas en la
unidad transatlántica dijo que las
relaciones entre Alemania y Estados
Unidos estaban en su mejor momento y se
comprometieron los dos líderes a seguir
trabajando para ayudar a Ucrania en su
defensa contra Rusia el tiempo que sea
necesario y con los recursos que sean
necesarios y Cristóbal por otro lado
dejando al lado la guerra en Ucrania que
otros temas son prioridad en la agenda
de ambos países
de hecho en llamadas previas a este
encuentro que oficiales de la Casa
Blanca Siguen con periodistas el tema de
China fue uno de los temas que más se le
preguntó a los oficiales de la Casa
Blanca sobre si iba a ser uno de los
temas que se iban a tratar antes
precisamente de la reunión a Puerta
cerrada de los dos líderes los
periodistas gritaron varias preguntas
sobre chinas y China estaba sobre la
mesa y es que preocupa mucho el tema de
que china vaya a ayudar no solamente a
nivel militar sino a nivel logístico a
Rusia en su ataque a Ucrania y lo que se
está discutiendo es Cuáles van a ser los
próximos pasos en caso de una eventual
ayuda china a Rusia y también está sobre
la mesa obviamente lo que se ha venido
preguntando mucho
los medios acá en Estados Unidos es
cuando va a ser el anuncio si lo hace el
presidente estadounidense sobre la el
envío de los aviones f-16 a Ucrania esto
Obviamente con el apoyo de Alemania que
termina siendo con el Reino Unido los
tres países que más ayuda militar y
ayuda financiera han dado Ucrania desde
que empezó la guerra además a es de
Resaltar que el fiscal general de
Estados Unidos Mary Garland estuvo y en
Ucrania hoy
Esto pues obviamente ha aprendido las
alarmas de porque el fiscal general de
Estados Unidos lleva a Ucrania y hay que
recordar que esta es su Segunda visita
desde que empezó la guerra también